สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันจันทร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนกันยายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วัน
อาทิตย์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 24
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนกันยายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ 201
ค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 26
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนกันยายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
ค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะ
ตอนนี้เวลา
22:00 น
:00 น
อันนี้เป็นตอนกลางคืนใช่ไหมคะ 4 ทุ่ม 41
นาทีเนี่ยอีกนิดเดียวก็จะ 5 ทุ่มแล้ว
อึกมากทำไมครูหญิงกับครูฟ้ายังไม่นอนอีก
คะ
ผู้หญิงกับครูฟ้าไม่อยากนอนแล้วค่ะผู้
หญิงจะนอนอีกเหรอคะ
กูยังไม่นอนค่ะกูพาผู้หญิงยังไม่ได้กิน
ข้าวเลย
ครูหญิง
22:00 นแล้วกูหยิ่งยังไม่กินข้าว
ยังไม่ได้กินเลยครูฟ้าเนี่ยผู้หญิงทำ
อาหารเสร็จแล้วก็มาเจอกับครูฟ้าเนี่ย
เสร็จแล้วก็จะไปกินค่ะ
ผู้หญิงไม่หิวหรอคะ
ไม่เป็นไรค่ะครูหญิงทำงานก่อนสอนภาษาไทย
เสร็จแล้วค่อยกินโอเค
ผู้หญิงมีน้ำค่ะ
มีชาเขียว
ชาเขียว
น่ากลัวมาก
อะไรนะ
จะเป็นอะไรหรือเปล่านะคะ
ไม่ใช่ Google เนาะหารูป
นี่ไง
ชาเขียว
แต่สีอันนั้นมันดูเขียวมาก
ผู้หญิงเสียวมาก
ผู้หญิงก็เห็นสีแล้วแบบ
ผู้หญิงกินๆแล้ว que หญิงจะเปลี่ยนเป็นสี
เขียวไหมชาเขียวขนาดนี้
แล้ว
จะไปกินข้าวค่ะ
ผู้หญิงโอเคก็โอเคค่ะเพราะว่า
กินข้าวแล้ว
หรอครูฟ้าก็อิ่มแล้วใช่ไหมคะ
อิ่มแล้วค่ะ
ขอบคุณค่ะไม่ต้องใกล้ขนาดนั้นก็ได้แล้ว
คู่ฟ้ากินอะไร
ครูฟ้าอ่ะ
ปิ้งย่างนะ
ครูฟ้ามีรูปให้ดูไหมคะ
เพราะกินอันนี้
ฟ้าขยับลงมาอีกนิดนึงนะคะครูฟ้าขยายที่
ไม่ใช่ปิ้งย่างนะคะ
กระเทียมนะคะอันนี้มีน้ำจิ้มอ๋อนั่นใช่
ไหมที่เป็นปิ้งย่าง
ครูฟ้ากินหมูปิ้งเหรอคะ
พอกินหมูปิ้งค่ะ
ป๊ามีลูกด้วยหรอคะ
ว่ามีหลานนะคะใบนี้ออกไม่ใช่ลูกนะคะ
เห็นแล้วอยากกินหมู
เห็นไหมครูหญิง
ก็ดีนะ
แต่เวลาที่ครูฟ้ากินเนี่ยครูฟ้ากินเร็วๆ
เร็วๆสิ
เอ้าครูฟ้าไม่ได้นะผ้าคลุมฟ้ากินเร็วๆ
เนี่ยเดี๋ยวครูฟ้าจะเป็นแบบผู้หญิงคนนี้
นะคะอร่อยเหรอดูนะดูหน้าเขาสิคะว่าน้ำเขา
เนี่ยอร่อยไหม
แอมมี่นะคะ
ไม่ใช่ค่ะ
อาหาร
ติดคอ
แฮมเบอร์เกอร์ติดคอ
แบบนี้ค่ะแบบแฮมเบอร์เกอร์ติดคอใช่ครูฟ้า
เนี่ยทำงานที่ร้านอาหารใช่ไหมเสิร์ฟอาหาร
ครูฟ้าต้องรู้ว่ากินอาหารเร็วๆแล้วอาหาร
ติดคอ
ไม่โอเค
ไม่ได้นะคะไม่โอเคเอาครูหญิง
กินอาหารเร็วๆแล้วอาหารติดคอหรอ
ใช่ไหม
คนทำอะไรคะ
Google  Google บอกว่าเวลาที่เรากิน
อาหารเร็วๆแล้ว
อาหารติดคอต้องไปอยู่ข้างหลังก็กดที่ท้อง
แบบนี้หรอ
ใช่มันต้องทำมือแบบนี้นะคะ
อ๋อ
กำมือไว้นะ
แล้วอันนี้ปากของเราใช่ไหมคะแล้วอาหาร
เนี่ยมันจะกระเด็นออกมาใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะครู
หญิง
ขอบคุณค่ะ
หลายๆคนไม่รู้นะคะ
คือคนไทยรู้เยอะนะ
แต่ครูฟ้าเรียน
ที่ college นะคะที่โรงเรียนเพื่อนๆก็ไม่
รู้
ครูก็ไม่รู้ค่ะ
แต่ครูหญิงเห็นน่ะที่
ร้านอาหารใช่ไหม
เวลาเรา
ไปที่ร้านอาหาร
หนิงก็จะเสิร์ฟรูปให้นักเรียนดูนะคะ
เนี่ย
ใช่ไหม
ที่ร้านอาหารน่ะเขาจะต้องมีรูปติดเอาไว้
นะครูฟ้า
จริงหรอครูหญิงติดว่ายังไง
สักครู่นะคะ
อินเตอร์เน็ตคุณหญิงช้าอยู่นะคะนักเรียน
[เพลง]
มีรูป
ติดเอาไว้ว่าถ้าอาหารกินอาหารแล้วอาหาร
ติดคอ
ต้องทำแบบนี้ไงผู้หญิงเห็น
[เพลง]
แต่ว่าถ้าอยู่ประเทศไทยเนี่ยนะคะที่
ประเทศไทยนะเนี่ยครูหญิงเห็นที่ร้านอาหาร
ที่อเมริกาไม่ใช่ที่ไทย
ที่ไทยไม่มีนะคะ
ไม่มีไม่มีค่ะแต่ที่ไทยเนี่ยนะคะอาหารติด
คอเนี่ยอาจจะน้อยนะถ้าที่ไทยเนี่ยนะคะน่า
จะเป็นอันนี้ติดคอเยอะกว่านะครูฟ้าอะไร
ก้างปลานี่ปลาใช่ไหมคะ
เวลาที่เรากินเนี่ยเราก็กินเนื้อปลากิน
กินเนื้อปลาเสร็จแล้วเนี่ยก็จะเหลือ
เหลือแค่ก้างปลา
ก้างปลา
เนี่ย
คนไทยเนี่ยเวลานักเรียนไปร้านอาหารที่ไทย
นะคะร้านอาหารที่ไทยถ้านักเรียนสั่งเมนู
ปลา
เอ่อ
99 จุด 99%
เขาจะเสิร์ฟทั้งตัวนะคะ
เมนูปลาเนาะที่เป็นส่วนใหญ่อ่ะนะคะเขาจะ
เสิร์ฟทั้งตัวคือของนักเรียนเนี่ยเขาจะ
หั่นใช่ไหมปลาเป็นตัวแบบนี้แล้วเขาก็จะมี
มีด
แล้วก็หั่นเป็นชิ้นใช่ไหมเป็นชิ้นแล้วก็
ทำอาหารแล้วก็เสิร์ฟใช่ไหมคะแต่ที่ไทย
เนี่ยไม่ค่อยมีคนไทยชอบปลาเป็นตัวไงปลา
เนี่ยมันก็จะมีอ้างปลาแล้วบางครั้งมันก็
จะมีแบบก้างเล็กๆ
ก้างเล็กๆอย่างนี้ค่ะ
ก้างมันเยอะนะคะนักเรียนก้างปลาอยู่นะคะ
บางทีเรากินเข้าไปอ่ะแล้วไม่ใช่อาหารติด
คอนะคะก้างปลาเนี่ยติดคอ
[เพลง]
อันนี้เป็นคอของเราใช่ไหมอันนี้เป็นหัว
แล้วข้างในคอเนี่ยก็มี
ก้างปลานะคะนักเรียนอันนี้
มีก้างปลาติดคอถ้าก้างปลาติดคอ
ทำแบบนี้
โอเคไหมคะก้างปลาจะออกมาไหม
เออไม่รู้อ่ะนักเรียน
จ้างมามัน
เป็นแบบนี้ไหมแล้วมันก็อยู่อย่างนี้ไหม
ใช่ๆมันจะเล็กเนี่ยมันจะขวางคอเราอยู่
อย่างนี้แหละ
แล้วแบบเราจะกินอาหารได้นะในเวลาเรามี
ก้างปลาติดคอแล้วเราดื่มน้ำเนี่ย
พอเรากลืนลงไปแล้วรู้สึก
เจ็บ
เพราะมันก้างปลาอยู่ที่คอใช่ไหมคะเวลาที่
ครูฟ้าครูฟ้าเคยก้างปลาติดคอไหม
เอ่ยค่ะครูฟ้าเคยก้างปลาติดคอแน่นอนค่ะ
ตอนเด็กๆ
ตอนครูฟ้าอายุ 2 ขวบ
มันน่าจะโตกว่านั้นนะ
คิดเหมือนกันนะคะ
ใช่ๆครูฟ้าก็กินปลาใช่ไหมกินปลาแล้วบางที
เราไม่ได้ดูโอ้ผู้หญิงเข้าใจเลยค่ะครูฟ้า
เนี่ยเวลากินข้าวไม่ใส่แว่น
มองไม่เห็น
มองไม่เห็นมองไม่เห็น
เวลามีปลามา 1 ตัวใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้าก็แกะกิน
แล้วก็กินเนื้อปลาใช่ไหมมองไม่เห็นว่ามี
ก้างปลาในเนื้อปลาที่ภูฟ้าตัดมาเนี่ยมี
ก้างปลาอยู่หรือเปล่าครูฟ้าก็กินเข้าไป
แล้วก็ก้างปลาติดคอ
ตอนที่ครูฟ้าเด็กๆแล้วก้างปลาติดคอทำยัง
ไง
มันก็จะมีคุณแม่นะคะ
ค่ะ
คุณแม่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะคะบอกว่า
คุณแม่บอกว่าคือฟ้า
เอาข้าวค่ะนักเรียน
ผู้หญิงมีรูปครูฟ้าไม่เป็นไร
ใช่คุณแม่บอกให้กินข้าวเข้าไปค่ะ
แต่ไม่ต้องเคี้ยว
ตักข้าวใช่ไหม
กลืนเลยไม่ต้องเคี้ยว
ไม่ต้องนะคะ
อันนี้เป็น
ก้างปลาอยู่ที่นี่ใช่ไหมถ้าครูฟ้าเคี้ยว
มันก็ไม่ทำอะไรใช่ไหมคะแต่ถ้าครูฟ้ายัง
เป็นเม็ดแต่ไม่ใช่ทั้งหมดนี้นะ
ครูฟ้าก็จะมีช้อนแล้วก็ตัดเข้านิดหน่อย
แค่นี้เนาะแล้วก็กลืนข้าวอยู่ที่นี่มันก็
จะดันก้างปลาลงมาใช่ไหม
ใช่ค่ะ
ก้างปลาที่คอที่มันติดอยู่ที่คอก็จะไม่มี
ก็ไม่มี
มันก็โอเคนะคะ
ผู้หญิงคิดว่าอันนี้ก็เป็นสิ่งที่คนไทยนะ
90%
ทำอาจจะ 99 เลยไหม
นักเรียนให้ย่างปลาเนี่ยมันลงไปในคอนะคะ
คนไทยกินข้าวไงก็จะใช้ข้าวนะคะหรือขนมปัง
ก็โอเคนะคะ
ขนมปังเนี่ยมันเป็นแผ่นใช่ไหมเนี่ยมัน
เป็น
มันเป็นแผ่นๆใช่ไหมคะนักเรียน
มันเป็นแผ่นแบบนี้เนี่ยคือเอาลงไปทั้งหมด
เนี่ยไม่ได้นะคะส่วนใหญ่คิดว่าถ้าเป็นขนม
ปังเนี่ยเราก็จะเอาผักมาแล้วก็ปั้นไหม
อันนี้คือข้าวเหนียวนะคะนักเรียนข้าว
เหนียวนะคะ
เพราะว่า
คนไทยก็จะกินข้าวเหนียวด้วยแต่ว่าไม่ใช่
คนไทยทุกคนที่มีข้าวเหนียวที่บ้านไง
คนไทยคืออันนี้เป็นประเทศไทยใช่ไหมคะ
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยก็จะมีตรงนี้เนาะ
ก็เลยใช้ข้าว
กลืน
กลืนลงไปนะคะกลืนลงไป
ก็โอเค
คุณฟ้าเคยใช้ขนมปังไหมคะขนมปังแล้วปั้น
ปั้นเป็นก้อนกลมๆไม่เคยค่ะว่าเคยใช้แต่
ข้าวขนมปังไม่เคย
ผู้หญิงก็ไม่เคยนะผู้หญิงก็เวลาก้างปลา
ติดคอแบบยิ่งตอนเด็กๆอ่ะนะเราจะรีบกินไง
รีบกินก้างปลาแบบบางทีไม่ได้ดูให้ดีๆนะคะ
กลางปลามันก็ติดคอหรือว่าคู่ฟ้าบางคนเขา
ก็บอกว่าให้ใช้
ใช้อะไรคะ
สมมุติว่าเรามีใกล้กว่าติดคอ
คุณแม่ครูฟ้าก็บอกว่าลองดื่มน้ำ
ดูนะคะดื่มน้ำ
แต่ครูฟ้าไม่โอเคอ่ะดื่มน้ำแล้วก็ยังไม่
โอเค
ใช่ไหมผู้หญิงก็คิดว่าอย่างนั้นเหมือนกัน
ไงอันนี้คอของเราเนาะอันนี้ก้างปลานะคะ
นักเรียน
ใช่ผู้หญิงก็คิดว่าแบบถ้าน้ำ
มันเป็นน้ำเหมือนนักเรียนเวลาเราดื่มน้ำ
เข้าไปน้ำมันก็จะผ่านตรงนี้มันก็จะไหลลง
ไปใช่ไหมคะ
ก้างปลาน้ำก็จะลงมาที่นี่ก้างปลาก็ยัง
อยู่ที่เดิมไง
แต่ผู้หญิงเคยเคยได้ยินนะอันนี้ไม่รู้
จริงหรือไม่จริงแต่เคยได้ยินบางคนบอกว่า
เป็นน้ำมะนาวครูฟ้า
น้ำมะนาวเหรอ
ใช่ค่ะ
มะนาวใช่ไหมนักเรียนหรือว่านักเรียนจะมี
เลมอนนะคะมะนาวเนี่ยมันจะเปรี้ยวใช่ไหม
เปรี้ยวเขาบอกว่าก้างปลาเนี่ยมันก็เหมือน
กับกระดูกของเราอ่ะ
เราเนี่ยมีกระดูกใช่ไหมคะมีกระดูกแต่ปลา
เนี่ยมันจะมีกระดูกที่เป็นก้างแบบนี้เขา
บอกว่าให้บีบน้ำมะนาวมีมะนาวใช่ไหมแล้วก็
อ้าปากแล้วก็บีบน้ำมะนาวลงไป
เพราะน้ำมะนาวลงไปมันจะเหมือนกับมันเป็น
a10 เค้าเรียกอะไรนะ Acid หรอเป็นกรดอะ
ค่ะนักเรียนแล้วตรงนี้แล้วก้างปลาจะแข็งๆ
มันจะนิ่มๆอ่ะหรอผู้หญิงไม่รู้เหมือนกัน
อันนี้เคยได้ยินมาแต่
ไม่รู้อ่ะค่ะเพราะอย่างที่เราบอกนะว่าคน
ไทย
99% กินข้าวข้าวเหนียวหรือว่าขนมปังอะไร
ก็ได้ที่เรามีบ้านแต่ว่าก้างปลาไม่น้ำ
มะนาว
ไม่รู้นะคะไม่เคยเหมือนกันอันนี้เคยได้
ยินนะคะหรือว่าบางคนเนี่ยนะคะเขาก็บอกว่า
เวลาก้างปลาติดคอมันมีก้างปลาอยู่ที่นี่
ใช่ไหมนักเรียนก็ไม่ได้กินข้าวไม่ได้กิน
ข้าวเหนียวไม่ได้ดื่มน้ำบางคนเนี่ยล้วงคอ
ล้วงคอก็คือคุณเอานิ้วเนี่ยใส่ลงไปใช่ไหม
คะให้เรารู้สึกแบบเอาก้างปลาเนี่ยออกทั้ง
ปากของเรา
[เพลง]
สมัยเวลาที่เราเอานิ้วล้วงเข้าไปในคอเรา
จะรู้สึกแบบอยากจะอ้วกก้างปลาเนี่ยมันก็
จะออกมา
[เพลง]
ไม่นะคะหรือกลัวที่สุดเลยครูฟ้า
ก็คือ
ก็คือไปโรงพยาบาลค่ะ
โรงพยาบาล
โรงพยาบาลก็ไปหา
หมอ
ใช่
คุณหมอก็จะดูคอให้นะคะนักเรียนแล้วคุณหมอ
เนี่ยก็จะเอาก้างปลา
ออกมา
คุณหมอก็จะมีอะไรเหมือนเป็นที่คีบไหม
คะนักเรียน
ครูฟ้าเคยก้างปลาติดคอแล้วไปหาคุณหมอที่
โรงพยาบาลไหมคะผู้หญิงไม่เคยเลยอ่ะผู้
หญิงก็คือกินข้าวนั่นแหละ
เพราะไม่เคยเหมือนกันค่ะเพราะว่าฟ้าก็
กินข้าวแล้วก็โอเคนะคะ
บางคนคิดว่าคนทำคุณหมอน่ากลัวจังเลยคะ
เนี่ย
คิดว่าถ้าบางคนไทยที่จะไปหาคุณหมอนะคะก็
คือก้างปลาติดคอเนี่ยกินข้าวแล้วแบบพอเอา
ข้าวเนี่ยกลืนข้าวลงไปแล้วไม่โอเคยังมี
ก้างปลาอยู่หรือว่ากินข้าวเหนียวกินขนม
ปังดื่มน้ำ
แล้วก้างปลาเนี่ยมันยังติดอยู่โอเคไม่รู้
ทำยังไงแล้ว
รอ 1 วัน 2 วันแล้วก็ยังมีก้างปลาอยู่ที่
คอเจ็บเนอะก็มันเจ็บนะคะนักเรียนเวลาที่
เราแบบเราต้องพูดเราไม่ต้องพูดก็ได้นะแต่
เราต้องกลืนกลืนกลืนน้ำลายบ่อยๆไงในปาก
ของเรามันมีน้ำลายใช่ไหมแล้วก็ต้องกลืน
แล้วมันจะรู้สึกเหมือนที่คอเนี่ยมีอะไร
ตลอดเวลามันมันไม่ได้นะคะเราก็คิดว่าถ้า
ทำแล้วไม่โอเครอแล้ว 2 วัน
2 วันแล้วก็ยังไม่โอเคที่ว่าเราก็ต้องไป
หาคุณหมอที่โรงพยาบาลนะคะหรือจริงๆแล้ว
นักเรียนบอกว่าถ้านักเรียนกินปลาแล้วก้าง
ปลาติดคอนักเรียนก็คือไปโรงพยาบาลเลย
ให้มันจบ
ใช่ค่ะก็ไม่รู้นะคะเวลาไม่รู้เหมือนกัน
ว่านักเรียนมีไหมเนาะนักเรียนทำยังไงเวลา
ก้างปลาติดคอก็คอมเมนต์คุยกับเราได้นะคะ
ส่วนวีดีโอนี้เราสองคนไปก่อนเนาะแล้ว
เดี๋ยวเราเจอกันใหม่วีดีโอหน้านะคะนัก
เรียนสวัสดีค่ะ